[Music]
foreign
well hello there watching The Press
preview a first look at what is on the
front pages time then to see what's
making the headlines with broadcaster
and political commentator Salma Shaw and
columnist and broadcaster Steve Richards
welcome to both of you
um no guesses tonight I guess let's take
a look shall we at the front pages the
Royal Rumble put your dukes up that's
how the Daily Star reports the story of
Prince Harry's new book with him William
pictured in boxing gloves as the war of
words between them escalates well
according to the express there's now no
chance of her being reconciled with his
family because he's quote unquote sold
his soul Harry spills his secrets in
devastating Memoir that is the front of
tomorrow's times the eye sums the story
up as the worst crisis the UK monarchy
has faced for 30 years
the sun focusing on some specific Harry
Revelations including the fact that he
took cocaine and smoked cannabis
the telegraph reports how Harry and
William both asked Charles not to marry
Camilla even though they accepted her
into the fold after their mother's death
but the male treats the whole thing with
disdain their headline oh spare us
the financial times leading with the
government's plans for new anti-strike
laws to keep essential Services running
during industrial disputes and the
guardian also has that story with
criticisms from the very trade unions
the new Lord targets does show of course
Harry and William
but don't forget by scanning the QR code
that you'll see on screen during the
program you can take a full look at
those front pages for yourself while you
listen to our guests so let's head
straight to them goodness me what a day
I mean Steve what happened in Spain did
they not get the memo
yeah well it's it's one of the many
interesting elements to this story that
even someone with a kind of powerful
media hold as the author of this book uh
can't actually control uh the narrative
and um this book has emerged people have
now got hold of it and read it uh and
has produced this range of front pages
and it's really interesting I mean it's
so uh much more explosive I think than
some had anticipated they've actually
every front page chooses a different
element to it
um so yeah it emerged from Spain but of
course it would I mean that's
interesting but it would all have
emerged anyway and what I find
interesting in it I mean I'm not
interested in him to be honest I'm not
usually interested in Royal stories but
this is fascinating when you have a
rebel within the establishment uh on
this scale there will be all kinds of
consequences I think well many of the
newspapers going on some of those
detailed Revelations include including
the Daily Express I killed 25 Taliban
fighters William attacked me he's my
arch nemesis I asked father not to marry
Camilla I took cocaine Megan told Kate
she had baby brain and so on I mean it
was like speed reading for journalists
today wasn't it Salma and translating
from Spanish too it has to be said
um he's good what he's gone full
Californian cathartic download here why
why does he think everybody wants to
know all this
well I'm afraid none of us can really
determine what it is that uh Prince
Harry wants to gain from this and I
think there is going to be some kind of
backlash I think further down the line
from him exposing you know his personal
private uh thoughts and experiences and
indeed that of his family and possibly
friends as well
um you know and what that actually is
ultimately going to mean when he looks
back on this once this is all now out of
the bag I think there is obviously deep
personal issues associated with the very
unique and challenging role that he
undeniably has being born into the
British royal family I think there is a
question as to whether this was the
appropriate way of
um and talking about this but clearly
there are going to be some questions for
the royal family and particularly
Buckingham Palace to consider because
there's there's a sort of different
approach this now and you've mentioned
that it's Californian and having this
absolute download and exposing
everything and all his secrets and his
innermost thoughts and now that that
Genie is out of the bottle it's going to
be very difficult for people to sort of
keep them the Mystique of the royal
family alive in the same way so they are
going to have to consider even if they
didn't respond to what is in the book
they are going to have to consider how
they think about themselves as an
institution now that you know some of
some of that Mystique has diminished as
a result of this yes I mean you know how
the newspapers cover this is fascinating
you know we know some of them like the
the the the male I suppose male male and
Sunday more pertinently has had a gripe
with the uh with the sussexes but but
Steve what what can we learn about the
attitude to this from the way they are
covering it tonight
well even if they're condemning it they
still put it on the front page so the
Daily Mail have to share us and it's on
the front page and I bet it's on the
inside Pages too so
um they know that this continues to sell
and they will run stuff in the build up
to the TV interview on Sunday and then
there will be more stuff and then one
way or another even if the rest of this
family don't respond that will be a
story too and so it's going to carry on
and I've always wondered what would have
happened if Diana had lived because if
you have one figure in this weird weird
institution not willing to stick to the
rules it becomes a very fragile edifice
now she died I don't believe in any of
the conspiracy theories but if she had
lived she'd have been trouble I suspect
well now they've got trouble in capital
letters from her son and there is a
connection there's a moving bit isn't
there about how he's been to the tunnel
where she died and I think a lot of it's
still to do with the mother the way she
was treated
um but we I don't know I've never met it
so you can't really analyze but I think
it's it's making the whole edifice quite
fragile yes um he says that he asked a
driver to replicate the journey that his
mother Diana took in the lead up to her
death um saying it was in Paris or he
was in Paris for the 2007 Rugby World
Cup semi-final and was 23 at the time he
also said that he he claimed a woman
relayed him a message from Diana saying
that he is living the life she couldn't
um so there's all sorts of details like
that
um The Daily Telegraph picking up on the
please don't marry Camilla we'll welcome
her into the fold but don't marry her I
mean it's a case of take your pick there
are so many lines from this
um are there not
um but I guess the times
well sums it all up does it not Harry
spills his secrets in devastating Memoir
um we've talked about you know why spill
the secrets but why be so devastating
and what impacts Salma will this have on
the Royal Family
I think the the impact of the royal
family in the first instance I think
will be just about that that split that
we've seen between people who are sort
of vehemently in support of the royal
family you know no matter what and and
those people who think that uh Harry and
Megan were absolutely right to leave
um so we'll see a continuation of that
for a while but there's going to have to
be some deep thinking especially in
advance of the coronation as to how this
perhaps changes some of the processes
behind the scenes and how they think
about those members of the royal family
that have massive exposure
um to the public and you know
considering how they are being for want
of a better phrase you know looked after
and how those systems and processes are
supporting them because ultimately you
know Prince Harry is a human at the end
of the day and and will have the same
fragilities and and difficulties that
everybody else faces but I mean you
listed a couple of those
details I mean and the book is full of
so many different details about his life
varying from you know his his
relationship with his brother to um his
own personal experiences in the Army he
talks about how he's killed 25 Afghans
whilst he was on duty there and I think
that some of this is also going to as I
say before it will it will rebound on
him I think personally because he has
made himself very vulnerable Now by
exposing absolutely everything
um in his life in this book and that is
really difficult to walk back from not
just for the royal family in terms of as
I say lifting that Mystique but also for
him being able to move forward now that
he himself in his own words has put all
these details out about himself yes and
actually the the point about
um I killed 25 Taliban fighters makes
the front page of the Daily Mail
astonishment as he declares that and
he's already raised concerns about his
own security
um moving on to the Sun as well another
Revelation which raised eyebrow eyebrow
eyebrows um about his drug taking I
binged at 17. I lost my virginity in a
pub field you know Selma's right Steve
you can't unshare once you've shared
no but he's already if you like step
back from the whole obligations of that
Royal Institution and they've uh
accepted him stepping back so he's now
in that respect I think speaking as a
celebrity and people will be interested
or not interested in that but when he
sort of shines a light on some of the
things that go on or alleges that goes
on that demystifies this institution and
this institution can only work with
mystery and near silence you know in the
90s they were all getting divorced left
right and center but somehow it held
together as an inverted commas a family
because of the near silence and then
people could read into it what they
wanted and a huge amount is invested in
this kind of institution now when you
have someone humanizing it to this level
as I said earlier I think it does uh
challenge the premise on which people
can to relate to it those who do
um and and that I think is the danger
for the royal family the fact that he's
revealing stuff about himself well that
will kind of Interest people who are
following him very closely
um but he's a celebrity now so that's
the interest in that side of it I think
yeah no doubt more details will come as
more people read more and translate more
until we wait for uh the UK copies um I
see that uh booksellers here say they're
under strict embargo still despite what
happened in Spain lots more still to
come including on the front page of the
times will the nurses meet the
government halfway on pay looking at
that next
foreign
[Music]
view with me once again broadcaster and
political commentator Salma Shaw and
columnist and broadcaster Steve Richards
um back to the real world with a bump
then um Steve if we head to strike news
from page of the times and the guardian
for different reasons first of all the
times an interview with Pat Cullen
General Secretary of the Royal College
of Nursing an indication of some
movement from her meeting the government
halfway on their pay demands
yeah I think this was always going to
happen I mean you make a demand this one
originally was quite High wasn't it 18
19 or something
um and you move
um that's what happens in negotiation
the only missing element in this has
been the negotiation because so far
ministers in England has been slightly
different in Scotland and elsewhere
um have been resistant to negotiate at
all my guess is and sense is that that
will change and they will have to reach
some sort of setting no idea what the
figure will be but they will have to
reach some kind of uh uh settlement with
the nurses the times has been told that
the union could be willing to accept a
pay rise of about 10 percent let's
discuss it we've just had word from the
Department of Health and Social care uh
their statement
um this the Secretary of State wants to
have an honest conversation with the RCN
about what is Affordable and pay
settlements for next year during these
challenging times and is Keen to meet
for discussion as soon as possible but
then they're going to say they've
accepted the pay review body in full
they've given NHS workers a pay rise of
at least 1400 pounds and this on top of
a three percent pay increase last year
when public sector pay was frozen but a
suggestion is of course they'll be
talking about next year's pay settlement
not this
um The Guardian leading on unions
attacking the prime minister's plan to
SAC workers who break strike rules that
news of today
um but the big spectacle I guess of
today's Selma was the um funeral service
for the former Pope Pope Benedict XVI
yes and uh what's interesting about this
is that uh the the pope presided over uh
the funeral of uh his predecessor uh and
it's the first time that you've had this
situation because of course the pope
before this had never retired before
Pope Benedict and um it was quite an
interesting service because the pope
himself is now 86 and looking quite
frail but obviously he insisted on doing
this and so many people I know that
you've just seen in your own uh package
from Sky News you know Vincent Nichols
the leader of the Catholic church in in
Britain
um has gone over as well so a very sort
of important and historic moment uh for
the Catholic church and I don't think um
a
spectacle we'll see again given the very
specific scenario um that this is this
has culminated from yes and
extraordinary pictures once again from
the from the Vatican there Salma Shah
Steve Richards thank you both